also ich muss ehrlicherweise sagen dass
sie das gehört habe habe ich den
eindruck gehabt
es ist wieder typisch deutschland wir
machen der bürokratie die einfach zu
kompliziert ist und statt pragmatisch
die kids mit allen din a 4 zettel noch
zu verkaufen und da die anweisungen die
hinweise wie so ein test durchzuführen
ist gegeben ist ist es nicht schwierig
das ist eigentlich sehr einfach und dazu
brauchen wir auch kein medizinstudium um
seinen test durchzuführen
und man kann es dem laien zu trauen und
es ist relativ simpel eine pdf-datei
herzustellen und das einfach der packung
zusätzlich zu geben ich verstehe jetzt
nicht warum ich so bürokratisch
kompliziert machen müssen in unserem
land wie ich bin jetzt erst einmal froh
dass von seiten des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums auch an
diese initiative oder dieser
verordnungsermächtigung endlich erlassen
worden ist hintergrund war dass wir
letzte woche im bundestag als
fdp-fraktion entsprechenden antrag rein
hereingebracht haben übrigens auch die
grünen fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
haben das ebenfalls gemacht und rein
zufällig kann dann entsprechende
referentenentwurf für eine veränderung
der folgen für medizinprodukte abgabe
verordnung und seiten der regierung in
den usa und auch in österreich sind es
schon lange erhältlich warum dauert das
bei uns so lange außerhalb jetzt der
packungsbeilagen panne
ich denke am anfang war es tatsächlich
so das ist ein erster vorbehalt
existiert dass viele von den
landespolitikern gesagt haben teste
dürfen eigentlich nur ärzte ausführen
aber das ist gerade einer pandemie
situation wirklich nicht zielführend wir
müssen niederschwellig diese
testangebote ermöglichen
es geht ja auch letztendlich darum dass
man zb altenpflegeheim seine lieben
besuchen können oder auch in die schule
gehen wenn man unsicher ist die texte
sind nicht hundertprozentig das wissen
wir alle aber es gibt eine sicherheit
die allen zugänglich gemacht werden
müssen und wenn es in ländern wie usa
und österreich funktioniert kann so
etwas auch in unserem land funktionieren
ich bin froh dass wir auch uns hier
bewegt haben unserem land